en este vídeo quiero platicar más a
detalle porque utilizamos el promedio de
los dos extremos en vez de utilizar los
extremos como base al hacer nuestros
cambios porcentuales cuando hacemos
cuentas de la elasticidad la idea
básicamente es que queremos que nos dé
lo mismo un cambio porcentual de ida que
de regreso así que aquí vamos a hacer un
ejemplo de las dos formas de la forma
tradicional y de la forma que se hace
matemáticamente de manera usual es decir
con uno de los extremos y también lo
vamos a hacer de la forma pues correcta
entre comillas cuando estamos trabajando
en economía vale entonces para esto
vamos a acordarnos de que decía nuestra
fórmula de elasticidad de la demanda
aquí vamos a hacer un ejemplo con
elasticidad de la demanda pero pues
ejemplos similares se pueden hacer con
elasticidad cruzada de la demanda o bien
con la elasticidad de la oferta pero
bueno la elasticidad de la demanda era
el cambio porcentual cambio porcentual
en la cantidad
este triangulito es delta de cambio
dividido entre el cambio porcentual del
precio y justo el detalle es que para
estos cambios porcentuales pues podemos
hacerlo de la forma matemática que es
hacer el por ciento tomando los extremos
como base o bien de la forma de economía
que es tomando el promedio de los dos
como base y cuya ventaja es que nos da
lo mismo
idea ave que debe a entonces vamos a
hacerlo de las dos formas para ver qué
sucede déjame empezar aquí y deja de
poner entre comillas que la forma
correcta correcta y le pongo entre
comillas porque osea no quiero dar un
juicio de valor o sea realmente son dos
formas distintas de hacerlo y esta es la
forma en la cual se hace en economía ojo
a lo mejor tu profesor de economía te lo
pida de una manera distinta pero
generalmente en economía se hace de la
siguiente forma la forma correcta entre
comillas es tomar los cambios
porcentuales con el promedio entonces
vamos a ver qué nos daría aquí aquí
tenemos yendo de a a b vamos a ponerle
que desde a
ave de a ave que tenemos pues al pasar
de ave el precio disminuye en uno aquí
es menos uno y la cantidad aumenta en
dos aquí es más 2 entonces según esta
fórmula
tendríamos que la elasticidad de la
demanda sería igual
y el cambio porcentual en la cantidad o
sea 2 dividido entre y aquí viene la
parte importante no es entre 4 ni entre
6 sino entre el promedio de 4 y 6 o sea
entre 52 quintos dividido entre el
cambio porcentual en el precio otra vez
ahora es un cambio de menos uno menos
uno dividido entre el promedio de 1 y 2
o sea entre 1.5 vamos a ver cuánto nos
da esto de acá a ver haciendo ley del
sándwich es de 1.5 sube acá con el 2 se
convierten en 3 y abajo nos queda el 5
entonces es menos tres quintos y este
menos es el de acá 1.5 por 2 nos queda 3
dividido entre 5 es menos tres quintos
esto de aquí es igual a pues un quinto
es punto 2 entonces esto es menos 0.6
muy bien entonces esta es la elasticidad
de la demanda haciéndolo de la forma
correcta yendo de a a b pero vamos a ver
qué sucede cuando vamos ahora debe
y también vamos dv entonces hacia arriba
el precio disminuye en dos y hacia
arriba perdón la cantidad disminuye en
dos y acá el precio aumenta en uno bueno
entonces que nos queda ahora calculando
lo de esta forma pues la elasticidad de
la demanda es igual a ahora tenemos un
menos dos menos dos dividido entre el
promedio de cuatro y seis entre cinco
dividido entre y abajo tenemos otra
fracción nos queda uno a uno dividido
entre y ahora el promedio de 1 y 2 entre
1.5 y si te das cuenta es exactamente la
misma cuenta dos quintos entre uno entre
1.5 con un signo menos aquí también
tenemos 22 quintos entre 1 entre 1.5 con
un signo menos o sea aquí tenemos de
nuevo menos tres quintos que es igual a
menos 0.6
entonces lo interesante es que estas dos
nos quedaron iguales va esa es la
ventaja de la manera correcta pero para
ver que pues realmente esto sólo sucede
en la manera correcta vamos a hacerlo
ahora de la manera otra vez entre
comillas incorrecta e incorrecta
y otra vez le digo incorrecta porque
ahorita estamos en economía si
estuviéramos en matemáticas pues ésta
sería la forma en la cual estaríamos
haciendo los cambios porcentuales
pero bueno o sea la idea ahora es que
vamos a hacer los cambios porcentuales
fijándonos en el extremos y en el
extremo aquí sería 2 aquí sería 4 yendo
de a a b y aquí debe a sería 1 y 6
entonces vamos a hacer las cuentas para
ver cuánto nos queda haciendo las
cuentas ya dije muchas de las cuentas
pero bueno hagamos las haciendo las
cuentas así entonces aquí la elasticidad
de la demanda yendo de a a b nos queda
un cambio de 2 nos queda un cambio de 2
dividido entre 4 ahora estamos tomando
el extremo verdad entre 4 y eso dividido
entre el cambio porcentual del precio
ahora es este menos uno menos uno pero
ahora sí dividido entre el extremo que
sería este 2 entre 2 entonces esto de
aquí cuando es el 2 sube para acá 2 por
2 es 44 entre menos 4 que es igual a
menos 1 ok entonces hasta ahorita ya
vimos cuánto nos da la elasticidad de a
avn y luego vamos a ver cuánto nos dan
déjame le le indicó que desde a a b a b
y ahora vamos a ver cuánto nos da debe
debe aa vale entonces la elasticidad de
la demanda debe a a ahora nos quedan a
ver es otra vez el cambio porcentual de
la cantidad ahora es menos dos menos dos
dividido entre y ahora tenemos que tomar
en cuenta este 6 verdad ahora este es el
extremo con el que empezamos y eso
dividido entre y ahora este es un 1 y
aquí tenemos otro
otro entonces estoy acá cuando da es
menos 2 entre 6 y aquí abajo tenemos 1
entonces menos dos sextos que es menos
un tercio observa ahora este con este
son distintos le voy a poner aquí
distintos distintos todo lo importante
digo aquí quedó todavía otra cosa más
distinta pero más bien lo importante es
que calculando de esta forma de la
manera correcta
no importa si vamos de a a b o si vamos
debe aa
obtenemos la misma elasticidad de la
demanda sin embargo acá en la manera
incorrecta entre comillas cuando vamos
de ave obtenemos un -1 pero cuando vemos
cuando vamos de b
obtenemos un menos un tercio sale
entonces esta es la razón por la cual en
economía para hacer los cambios
porcentuales nos fijamos en el promedio
en vez de tomar algunos de los extremos
como base